[Musique]
bienvenue dans l'entretien politique
avec comme invité philippe emmanuel le
maire de jouars pontchartrain bonjour
monsieur le maire bonjour monsieur
carmaux alors à le voir pour certains
beaucoup de gens connaissent et une en
effet une ville des yvelines d'à peu
près 6000 habitants qu'être longtemps
été traversé par la rn 12
jusqu'en 2003 je crois par chance voilà
maintenant elle est écartée donc il faut
ça a changé quand même ça la vie de la
vie de joueur pro chartrain le fait de
country pop ne soit pas obligé de la
traversée par la nationale écoutez ça
l'a complètement métamorphosé de ville
qui était une verrue elle l'est restée
une ville de passage de grand passage
puisque on y comptait plus de 40000
voiture qui traversait la régulièrement
en direction de dreux et normandie moi
quand je dit c'est vers ça et quand
j'étais petit mes parents du normand et
en prenait cette route qui était bordée
de commerces de restaurants routiers
la délégation a eu un effet assez
important puisque la ville s'est
transformé la commune rurale et s'est
transformée en une commune plutôt
résidentiel
ce qui a permis de mettre en valeur en
fait c'est à tous et notamment son
patrimoine historique de la faire un peu
plus connaître et d'une ville de passage
c'est devenu une commune où il fait bon
vivre où maintenant effectivement depuis
à peu près 15 ans une réalisation un
petit peu accéléré puisqu'on est passé
de 3000 habitants à signy ont annulé et
aujourd'hui c'est vu comme une menace et
assez prisé avec le phénomène de la
pandémie due qu'aux vide on s'aperçoit
que les projets par les parisiens intra
muros
elle chercha à quitter paris et se
réfugier dans les communes plutôt au
vert ont joué par les agences
immobilières et si on travaille
oui alors justement vous disiez vous
vous êtes vous menez à versailles vous
avez habité ensuite un mort pas je crois
que vous êtes installé un joueur pour
certains il ya une quinzaine d'années
vous avez été élu sur la liste du maire
précédent et vous avez démissionné après
des désaccords 2019 pour vous préparer à
cette candidature vous avez été élu au
deuxième tour des dernières élections
municipales
pourquoi vous avez voulu devenir mère
pour porter un projet c'est surtout pour
ça j'ai déjà eu l'occasion c'est le buzz
du premier mandat et adjoint aux
finances par l'équipe précédente
c'était ma première incursion dans le
monde politique dans l'ombre des
collectivités locales je vais trouver à
l'époque cet investissement absolument
enrichissant la capacité de pouvoir
faire changer des choses évoluent et
quand les élections ans se sont
présentées il y avait déjà un certain
nombre d'idées en tête de transformation
en fait de la vie communale qu'on a pu
avec mon équipe
en pratiquement deux ans travaille et
peaufiné pour construire un projet et
ses projets que nous avons présenté aux
habitants et ils l'ont retenu avec cette
élection tardive comme vous le dis si
monsieur carmouze puisque nous avons été
installés nous lé parlement le 3 juillet
2000 la csg regarder un petit peu d'eau
dans vos fondamentaux de votre campagne
électorale y avait plusieurs thèmes le
rassemblement au delà des différences
l'ouverture à tous les talents
l'intelligence collective la
bienveillance des ateliers participatifs
et démocratique
la citoyenneté assumé est impliqué est
ce que vous diriez au faut que la la
fonction de maire c'est une faction
politique mais une fonction politique
particulière différente
oui dans la politique est une politique
au sens pur grève tant que la politique
locale dans la cité il y six adjoints
chartres à 6000 habitants où il n'y a
pas de politique politicienne
la seule politique qui existe c'est
l'attention qu'on porte aux habitants à
essayer de faire que le vivre ensemble
soit le meilleur possible essayer de
piloter cette commune dans le respect de
sa ruralité et c'est très important pour
nous est que plus leur jeu voire
constatera à contre chartres ça veut
dire un congrès de chasse a toujours été
les communes qui étaient à la limite
d'un monde vers un autre donc
aujourd'hui c'est plutôt le monde urbain
qui est à nos portes des jo en notre
qualité donc la scène politique est une
politique de proximité moi c'est ce qui
m'a motivé de finalement on a développé
dans notre projet un axe de grande
proximité avec nos habitants donc là
m'ont mis en place immédiatement dès cet
été
en l'ouvrant beaucoup plus nos capacités
à dialoguer par exemple j'ai créé non
monsieur mercredi qui marche très très
bien où les gens de la commune peuvent
appeler sans rendez vous l'après midi
nous avons une permanence des élus
mais dimanche sur le marché
nous sommes mais je suis assez présents
sur les réseaux sociaux aussi c'est un
nouvelle façon de pouvoir commune et
communiquer en de la température sur
quel projet remontée aussi des idées
et puis comme vous l'avez dit le projet
que nous avons construit avec mon équipe
repose sur trois piliers et une
gouvernance moderne un peu en rupture
avec les anciennes pratiques
la démocratie implique et citoyenne donc
des six colis bleu permet à un gentil en
entrave à l'exercice de la citoyenneté
l'itie avec une centaine de participants
qui se sont inscrits dans différents
ateliers d'intelligence politique
et puis le dernier volet c'est la
transition écologique locale parce que
aujourd'hui on ne peut ne pas pas
ignorer que ricco logis total doit être
présente dans tout ce que nous faisons
et c'est peut-être localement on peut
avoir un impact important ou associé
avec les activités les autres communes
de notre bassin par département
finalement nationalement on peut
peut-être avoir un résultat plus rapide
je les politiques nationales ou
internationales comme je le disais je
vois un joueur pour chartres appartient
aux dix communes du département qui font
partie du plan petite ville de demain
c'est un essai au service du plan de
relance et des territoires sur les
territoires qu'est ce que ça implique
alors 7
cette distinction enfin le fait de faire
partie de 2,2 ce plan et quels espoirs
fondés vous serez justement cette
appartenance ce que ça implique pour
nous c'est une véritable opportunité
la sélection a été faite sur et sur le
projet communal sur nos intentions de
développement pour la commune il se
trouve que les idées portées par notre
projet est ce
qui sont déclinées par le projet de
ministère de la cohésion des territoires
de magro son talent ses voisins on y
parle d'écologie on y part de
revitalisation des centres bourgs
on y parle de développer les communes en
gardant leurs spécificités
donc nous ça nous allait très bien nous
avons candidater à la rentrée des
vacances et cette sélection est
intéressante parce que les petites
communes comme les nôtres qui avons des
idées mais des moyens finalement assez
limité pour réaliser nos projets et bien
ce type de booster que nous apportent
l'aide de l'état qui est une aide
conséquente et sur toute la durée du
mandat ça qui est intéressant
cette aide à se produire en capacité
d'ingénierie donc le gouvernement va
nous aider à financer des directions de
projets qui vont nous permettre un plan
territoire c'est très important quand on
cherche à se développer et essayer de
relever un peu la tête du quotidien qui
a une autre pour essayer de visualiser
et roux nous pourrions aller quelques
actions priorisées dans ce projet il y a
également financement puisque c'est 3
milliards d'euros que l'état a mené sur
la tap
pendant ce demis mandat pour 1000
communes en france donc c'est
significatif
je ne sais pas aujourd'hui combien nous
obtiendrons puisque d'après ce que j'ai
compris c'est une allocation et une aide
au financement par l'idée par projet
donc faut d'abord démarré clarifier ses
idées de l'amitié ses priorités et puis
on verra ce que nous obtiendrons en
termes de soutien
il n'y a pas de l'argent puisque il ya
également un soutien en termes
d'ingénierie c'est à dire que capacité à
réaliser à exécuter et puis également il
ya tout un réseau de partenaires qui
sont associés à l'initiative que le
ministère de madame gros a mis en oeuvre
nous fabriquer des solutions petit peu
près marché donc oui petit
moyennes communes comme la nôtre c'est
une aubaine pour nos habitants et pour
la commune délibérément un dernier mot
peut-être sur la crise de la cog vide
évidemment qui affecte beaucoup les
fonctions notamment des mères vous le
disiez tout à l'heure vous aviez envie
de faire des réunions avec les habitants
de loire pour chartrand c'est plus
compliqué aujourd'hui il ya la question
de la vaccination où il ya beaucoup de
mères qui prennent en main cette
motivation est ce que dans une petite
ville comme je vois pour chaque race est
possible ou est-ce que vous êtes obligés
d'attendre faut que l'état décide de
cette vaccination
la vaccination nous rend toutes ces
évolutions ces étapes ne pas savoir
qu'aujourd'hui la stratégie du
gouvernement évolué sur le sujet nous
nous l'avons appréhendé ce que vite puis
depuis notre arrivée cet été
bien sûr en inventant finalement
beaucoup de nos actions il ya du négatif
d'ailleurs on s'est mis à faire du
télétravail si on a développé des moyens
peu de vidéo conférence que nous
n'avions pas nous avons changé de nos
façons de travailler les commissions
municipales maintenant une partie en
présence hier une partie en distance
yale vis-à-vis de notre population
nous sommes impactés pour le vivre
ensemble
donc ça c'est un impact sur le moral de
nos habitants bien évidemment ce que
nous avions ici que des activités
sociales culturelles et sportives assez
développé tout ça a été relativement
stopper nous ont sorti un portail de
solidarité justement pour elle pour
aller au plus près de nos habitants les
plus fragiles on a travaillé avec la
région ile de france en 9 ans ça pour
lancer un espion
là dessus madame pécresse un buste
escaut vide
nous avons pu tester en technologie pcr
près de 300 personnes de la commune mais
de l'udc du bassin environnant
nous avons avec la commune d'à côté
neauphle-le-château monter un une entité
de tests positifs 9 à la maison médicale
intercommunale qui fonctionnent très
bien on a fait une campagne avant noël
pour permettre aux jeunes de pouvoir se
tester avant de rejoindre leurs parents
leur télé et je suis en train de
travailler actuellement avec l'équipe de
la région et puis les professionnels
locaux à une nouvelle campagne de tests
en attendant oxydation bien évidemment
nouvelle campagne de tests de pussy
antigénique camp et celles ciblées pour
dimanche prochain
voilà ce qu'on essaie de faire je dirais
que le coded à impacter aussi des
finances de la commune parce que ma
première phase eh bien nous avons dû
fermer nos écoles nos centres
d'activités et ça a été une perte de
revenus la cour ne pratiquement trois
cent mille euros de budget de
fonctionnement
voilà je répondais à votre question si
vous en avez sur le sujet très bien mais
j'ai joué de dollars dont on a fait un
petit peu le tour le tour de votre
commune vous dire viendra très
certainement en cours d'année merci vous
pouvez philippe-emmanuel merci bienvenue
à vous
[Musique]